it may be picturesque but this is a
landscape in peril the driest july in
over a century has left the river
itching well below where it should be
it's why southern waters imposed a
hosepipe ban for customers to protect
the environment and what they use we
know that people who use a host pipe
it's a thousand liters in for an hour
which is more than one person will use
in a whole week so we're just asking
people stop using water for some of
those things that perhaps aren't
necessary just while we've not got any
rain
ban only applies to households and not
businesses like this garden center
anyone caught breaking it could be fined
a thousand pounds but shoppers here are
supportive wary of our changing climate
i think we'll all have to uh try and do
different sort of planting in our
gardens more mediterranean things that
survive the survive the drought more
important things than grass especially
the rivers and the animals in the rivers
the fish i think the water companies
instead of looking after shareholders
should start investing in the future
southern's hoping peer pressure will
mean people follow the rules and is even
encouraging customers to snitch on
serial offenders
the ground here is unbelievably dry the
grass is well it's more like more like
straw
and so in these kind of conditions
anyone who is still using a hose pipe
will be pretty easy to spot because
their lawn will still be green while
everyone else's will be brown and
parched well at the moment it should be
at least higher
conditions
but wildlife campaigners say the onus to
save water shouldn't be on residents
alone calling on water companies to do
more to prevent leaks
these are short-term mitigation measures
you know there has to be something more
robust in the future we can't just rely
on putting hose bands in
just you know a little bit there's you
know infrastructure issues all over the
place with water companies
that need to be addressed that will save
a lot more water than we do just by not
just by using a hose pipe
and it's not just this region that's
suffering the drought has seen the
source of the thames outside siren
cester dry up shifting it five miles
downstream from its official start point
we are very concerned about the impacts
on river environments and wildlife in
those rivers and of course the hosepipe
ban is in in some areas is one of the
mechanisms to reduce consumption reduce
demand
another hosepipe ban will come into
force across kent and sussex next week
but there are now even parts of fife in
scotland where water is scarce and with
no end in sight to the hot dry weather
it may not be long before there are more
restrictions
ivor bennett sky news hampshire